i would like to hear again state that
106 is not
as is commonly believed a basic predator
on par
with an advanced shark scp-106 is a
sentient being
albeit a totally alien one scp-106
appears to be aware of several things
beyond the scope of pure instinct and
genetic memory
scp-106 consistently breaches at moments
where recovery and containment are
most difficult a fox may see his way out
of a trap but only a man will wait for
his captors to look away to escape
dr eloque from his paper on sentience
incontained humanoids
they say that patience is a virtue if
this
is true it's the only virtue that
scp-106 has in spades
the anomaly known as the old man had
been well behaved for months
sitting cross-legged in the center of
his containment chamber
his lipless mouth molded into a slight
grin
the old man had a reptilian-like calm to
him
never truly inactive just
waiting and nobody else can wait for
quite as long
as him he could go for years without so
much as twitching if he wanted to
but not today today was special
there were no clocks and no calendars
and scp-106s
sell but that was fine he remembered the
last day they locked him back up
and he'd been counting ever since
seconds minutes days
months the old man had all the time in
the world
and today it was all about to pay off
october 31st all hallows eve
the night when ghosts goblins and demons
come out to play
the old man almost chuckled at the
thought of it what a perfect day for
a containment breach one of the
foundation technicians observing 106
from a control room monitor spilled his
coffee when the old man got up and
started walking towards the wall
alarms went off and guards were
dispatched as a large dark stain
expanded on the wall
of the containment chamber and 106
walked through it not that any amount of
armed response would do them
any good the bullets passed right
through 106's inky flesh as he strolled
down the corridor towards the exit
he killed two guards and a researcher on
his way out just for the fun of it
he'd been a well-behaved creature for a
long time now
he'd earned an evening of letting his
purely metaphorical hair
down and when 106 decides to have a
night of good
fun horror is always sure to
follow this is the tale of one of
scp-106's most
infamous and horrifying containment
breaches
be warned the following isn't for the
faint of heart
you're about to learn why scp-106 is
still one of the most feared anomalies
in foundation
containment immediately the containment
site dispatched three of its best field
agents
agent park agent wang and agent drak
their task was simple locate scp-106
minimize potential casualties and
distract the sadistic anomaly long
enough for reinforcements to
come and contain the creature once again
for the last several years
these agents would eat sleep and breathe
all things 106 in preparation for a
moment just like this
they'd been drilled over and over again
on everything from the creature's
behavior
to the worst case scenario of what to do
if you get pulled into its nightmarish
pocket dimension
they were as trained as a person
possibly could be for this situation
and fitted with state-of-the-art
foundation equipment to boot
and yet they were still terrified
they passed through the streets of the
nearest city where containment experts
believed 106 was most likely to head
after its escape
people of all ages dressed in halloween
costumes were out enjoying the night
child-sized superheroes were hanging out
with even smaller villains
horror movie slashers were sharing
drinks with cops and nuns
countless candy-carrying zombies
wandered through the streets
none of them had any idea of the true
horror that walked among them
the three agents went over their
training silently in their minds
106 was intelligent more intelligent
than anyone back at the foundation
really gave it credit for it had planned
this
it knew that it could blend in among the
costume monsters that were sure to be
out tonight
nobody would be able to tell the
difference until it was
too late one such person was a young
woman named alice
dressed up as an angel her experience
that night would be
far from heaven's scent her boyfriend
had made the always classy move of
breaking up with her right before they
were supposed to head to a halloween
party
leaving her in a fit of emotional
distress and embarrassment
over the course of the next several
hours she obsessively reflected on her
ex-boyfriend's audacity and lack of
empathy towards her
burdening her mind and filling her head
with anxiety
his last words i'm sorry it's over
gradually became louder and louder in
her thoughts as she stumbled in sadness
away from the noise of the streets
towards a thicket of trees
she was in such despair she could barely
stand and as she staggered through the
vegetation
she didn't even notice the shuffling of
footsteps behind her
or that they were getting closer and
closer
and closer alice tripped and caught
herself against a nearby tree
that's when she noticed a sudden burning
sensation on the skin
of her hand she looked up and saw that
her hand was now coated in a sticky
tar-like substance
whatever it was it seemed to be eating
away at the tree
and she could hear the hiss of the
corrosive liquid as it melted the skin
of her hand
a twig cracked beneath her and she
turned to see the rotting old man
staring at her with a malicious grin
she screamed and began to run but the
alcohol had robbed her of her
coordination
she tried as hard as she could to escape
will cradling her burning hand
but it wasn't enough she felt the spike
of excruciating pain rock her nervous
system
the old man had reached into her back
like a man operating a puppet
his long burning fingers dripping with
corrosive grease had melted through her
skin
and grabbed her by the spine she
screamed in pain
but she was too far away not a soul
could hear her
and the only creature that could didn't
have anything
resembling a soul the creature grabbed
her and pulled her into its blistering
embrace
it smiled the whole time bearing every
rotten
tooth it held her in place burning the
rest of her body as the two of them sank
into the ground together
more acidic sludge pooling at their feet
alice screamed on
and scp-106 loved her all the more for
it
the screamers were its favorite by the
time agent drak parks and wang found
alice
it was hard to know that this had once
been a human but they knew one thing for
certain
that this was the work of the old man
and they suspected that he wasn't close
to being done with his campaign of
halloween
terror next came a little boy named
jason
and his unfortunate friends they were
dressed as the justice league
with jason leading the group as batman
all of them wearing costumes that made
them feel like true heroes
it had been a good night their bags
heavy with candy
as they walked down an alleyway they'd
passed through countless times on their
way home from school
they had no idea what was waiting for
them
a long gnarled hand dripping with black
ooze suddenly
shot out of the wall and grabbed the boy
dressed as superman
he screamed as he was pulled towards the
ooze his braces shining in the moonlight
and kept screaming until he disappeared
into the solid brick wall
the rest of the justice league broke
into frightened screams and scattered
but they weren't fast enough hands kept
emerging from the wall
grabbing the children burning them
pulling them into the dark
only jason got away running and
screaming as his friends were yanked
into the void
but no one gets away from the old man
that easily
a black puddle formed on the ground in
front of jason and the old man rose out
of it
still grinning its malicious spiteful
grin
jason fell to the ground his legs giving
out from the fear
but the old man didn't move he just
stared at him
sizing him up deciding what type of
torment would yield the most twisted
pleasure
the creature lifted something up to its
mouth something that might have been
mistaken for a piece of halloween candy
from a distance
but jason knew better it was a tooth and
jason could recognize the shining braces
still stuck to it
the old man put the tooth in his mouth
and crunched it like a jawbreaker
as jason almost passed out from the
sheer terror of
watching it to this day nobody knows why
the old man
spared jason but when agents drack parks
and wang found the boy
the only survivor from the massacre of
his friends he was gripping the metal
fragment from billy's tooth so hard that
it was embedded into his palm
but the night still wasn't over yet the
old man
still wanted to have just a little bit
more halloween
fun one little boy couldn't join in on
the halloween adventures all his friends
were having
he was stuck at home sick with a stomach
flu that had been going around
at school all he could do was sit and
watch scary movies as his mother
answered the door
passing out candy to the
trick-or-treaters that he wished he
could join he sighed as he heard his mom
at the front door giving candy to
pirates
zombies and vampires tomorrow would be
even worse when he was forced to watch
his friends eating their candy and
reminiscing about all the fun that he
wasn't involved in his self-pitying was
interrupted when he heard his mother
open the door to another
trick-or-treater
but this time there was no exchange of
words or candy
just a long blood curdling scream
the little boy quickly got up to
investigate his heart pounding in his
chest
the sound of his mother's pain kept
echoing down the hall
as the heavy footsteps of something else
approached
it rounded the corner and the little boy
saw it
in all of its horrifying glory
like something out of one of the old
horror movies he had been watching
only worse it was the rotting old man
dragging his dying mother along with one
hand that was stuck
right into the flesh of her chest and
grabbing her by the rib cage
he screamed and ran upstairs towards the
bathroom the only room in the house with
a lock
he could hear the plotting footsteps of
the creature following him up the stairs
followed by the sickening sound of what
must have been the old man
dropping his mother's body the little
boy slammed the bathroom door shut
locked it and collapsed against the wood
his face was hot and sticky with tears
but at least he was safe for the moment
surely someone had heard his mother's
screams and would come to save him
as he was imagining the police bursting
through the front door and gunning down
the monster
he heard a hissing sound coming from
above him he looked up
and saw the face of the old man melting
through the door
and smiling at him from above he tried
to scream
but the monster opened its mouth and a
tide of corrosive liquid hit him in the
face
moments later someone did burst through
the front door
but it wasn't the police it was the
three agents drawn to the old man's
location by a trail of violence and
acidic black mucus
and as far as 106 was concerned this was
a great thing
he had just finished breaking his last
set of toys
and the new ones were here right on
schedule
park fired at the creature but it wasn't
enough to save agent drak
he was standing just a little too close
and underestimated how fast the creature
could move
before he knew it he was being dragged
into a messy portal in the wall by an
entity that was beyond his darkest
nightmares
when he woke up he was in the one place
that anyone who knows about scp-106
hopes never to find themselves
the pocket dimension that labyrinth of
twisting rotting hallways where the old
man has total dominion
you'd rather be in hell under the care
of the devil himself than end up there
agent drak encountered horrors beyond
conception before he finally
mercifully died at the old man's hands
no weapons or training could save him no
amount of effort could dig him out of
this hole
he ran through the halls for four whole
days before
scp-106 finally got bored and started
taking him apart
but to agent drak those four days felt
like a wretched
eternity when they eventually found
scp-106
he was standing in a field stomping on
pumpkins out of boredom
he submitted to containment with
relatively little difficulty
as foundation field agents used
high-intensity lights to subdue him
cleanup crews applied amnesics and
generated cover stories
everything about the halloween night
massacre was swept under the rug
back in containment scp-106
once again set cross-legged on the floor
of his cell
sorting a little collection of his
victim's teeth like halloween candy
he sat and smiled mulling over the
memories of his delightful halloween
night
he'd be fine for another few months now
he could just sit and enjoy the thoughts
until the foundation got bored
and loosened the leash again 106
is a patient monster when the time came
he'd be ready he was always ready
now go check out scp-001 when daybreaks
and scp-3280 after the storm for more
terrifying tales from the scp
foundation